Ein Türke mit einem Jazzclub in Berlin –
das ist ziemlich ungewöhnlich.
Hier sind … Die kulturinteressierten
Menschen haben sowieso die Angewohnheit,
die Musik leben zu lassen, und deswegen ist
die Aufgabe hier um einiges leichter,
genau die Situation zu erschaffen, die die
Musik auch wirklich verdient hat oder braucht.
Und in der Türkei ist das nicht [so].
Und deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich dann
diesen Jazzclub nicht in der Türkei,
sondern hier habe.
Fast täglich steht im Berliner „A-Trane“ eine
andere Band auf der Bühne.
Der Club ist für seine intime Atmosphäre
bekannt –
nur rund 200 Zuschauer haben hier Platz.
Sedal Sardans Jazzclub ist eine Institution in
der deutschen Hauptstadt.
Also, das ist natürlich das größte Glück
eines jeden Veranstalters,
wenn man seinen Ort als voll sieht.
Wenn die Gäste kommen und [ich] auch die
Freude in ihren Gesichtern sehe,
dann macht mich das sehr glücklich.
Seit 1997 betreibt Sedal Sardan den
Jazzclub.
Das ist da, wo ich jetzt auf der Bühne ’ne
Ansage mache,
und ich weiß, dass ich da sehr nervös war.
Er ist stolz, dass hier auch schon die ganz
großen Musiker der Jazzszene
aufgetreten sind,
zum Beispiel der US-amerikanische
Jazzpianist Herbie Hancock.
Also, so Musiker wie Herbie Hancock oder
Marcus Miller, die bei mir aufgetreten sind,
das sind einmalige Geschichten.
Weil die tun das, um diesen Club zu
unterstützen.
Das heißt, so ein Support-Gedanke ist [da]
gerade in dem Augenblick, weil das …
Die waren auch mal unbekannt, jung, und wo
haben sie angefangen?
Wo haben sie sich entfaltet?
Wo sind sie groß geworden? Nämlich in
Clubs.
Ein Stammgast im A-Trane ist der deutsche
Trompeter Till Brönner.
Er hat seine Karriere hier begonnen und ist
immer noch mit Sedal Sardan befreundet.
Wann immer er kann, kommt er vorbei.
Jazzclubbesitzer sind was ganz Besonderes.
Sie sind eine eigene Spezies.
Und vor allem deswegen, weil,
wenn sie nicht gut sind, sind sie sofort weg
und keiner spricht über sie.
Bei Sedal geht das schon weit über 20,
25 Jahre mittlerweile,
und wer das von sich behaupten kann, der
muss einiges richtig gemacht haben.
Sedal Sardan kam mit 12 Jahren aus der
Türkei nach Berlin.
Den Jazz lernte er erst später zufällig bei
einer Reise in seine Heimat kennen –
und lieben.
Er ist hier im Berliner Bezirk Charlottenburg
verwurzelt,
wo viele einflussreiche Kulturschaffende
leben.
Im A-Trane sollen sich die Musiker nicht nur
auf der Bühne wohlfühlen.
Auch vor und nach den Konzerten kümmert
sich Sedal Sardan um seine Gäste.
Denn er ist nicht nur der Besitzer
des A-Trane,
er ist auch seine gute Seele.